theodore mccarrick the defrocked
archbishop of washington is pleading not
guilty this morning to child sex abuse
charges mccarrick was stripped of his
rank as a cardinal and removed from the
priesthood after the vatican confirmed
other allegations of abuse
these criminal charges in massachusetts
go back nearly 50 years so let's go now
to chris livesay in rome who has the
story of the for now anyway only u.s
cardinal ever charged with sex crimes
chris good morning to you a lot of
people following this case
good morning tony today marks a profound
day of reckoning not just for the
disgraced former cardinal but also for
the catholic church survivors hope that
his criminal trial means that no one no
matter how powerful is above the law
a shocking image of the former cardinal
no clerical garb and in criminal court
he was one of the most powerful
cardinals in america advising popes and
hobnobbing with presidents he even
claimed to champion victims as he did in
2002 upon returning from a sex abuse
summit at the vatican now on anyone who
has this problem who is who is credibly
accusative will never work in the united
states today that includes mccarrick
himself now 91 years old and he's rocked
by pope francis in 2019 after an
internal investigation concluded he'd
abused minors and seminarians for
decades
just as damning a vatican report last
year revealed john paul ii the pope who
made mccarrick a cardinal and archbishop
of washington d.c knew about the
allegations but ignored them cbs news
vatican consultant monsignor anthony
figueredo worked as mccarrick's
secretary for 20 years and spoke to him
shortly before today's arraignment the
first thing he said
is i do not want to end my life in this
way
so
he expects something serious to come
from this trial perhaps imprisonment
and even more stunning i want my
priesthood back it's almost as if he was
deluded about the damage he has caused
to victims above all
but also to the church and the loss of
faith of millions of catholics
this week pope francis said he's quote
not afraid of transparency or truth
now with this long overdue trial
survivors hope mccarrick's plunge from
grace will inspire others to break their
silence
so it means that no bishop is safe i
hope
that it has many
shaking in their boots those who have
covered up and those two who have abused
the former cardinal faces up to 15 years
in prison and while this is his first
criminal case he faces several other
civil suits one of those other accusers
says that to see the former cardinal in
court today makes today the happiest day
of his life gail
all right chris lucey reporting from
rome thank you